Dwight down
what's with the jeans nonsense I've been
wanting to show you this for a while
okay oh um oh is this well there's some
other stuff on the right there we
probably can hi I'm chemin and I'm here
to film and this is such a beautiful
Villa we're sitting with the first time
of my ever experienced in my life with
two young men and they have big hard
cock to offer me yeah this Villa is
really quaint place mm-hmm it's very
quick it's it's important that we know
the quaintness of the villa where she's
getting rammed by two guys so can I tell
you what I do love about Kenai yes
positive always looking on the bright
side she's not you know what I mean
the villas beautiful looker ya know I'm
smiling I looked up some stuff by the
way cuz last week we were talking about
what's the story
yeah Marin and I Yuri my theory was that
she used to be maybe heavily pursued and
that maybe now she wants a little charge
in her life a little anchor because
she's getting older and she's like well
I probably still have a few years left
where I'm holding it together might as
well just go all out right and then I
found this interviews is it another
interview with her and we learned a
little bit about her in this I pulled it
up to this motion we're gonna know her
backstory a little bit a little bit yeah
first of all I gotta say look at her
tits she her body's amazing she's 61
years old incredible she looks better
than me her abs oh my god crazy
Jesus these Asian ladies I tell you they
hold together well at white ladies we
fall apart yeah fuck white ladies it's
true we hit the wall 40 is the wall
fucking what tits are sagging wrinkles
you're going damn
so Kim is here oh god I'm pulling all
the way from the Midwest right yes by
the way the guy and she's such a lady
yeah the guy that does this in every
porn the interview guy they're always
the were kick you can imagine what
creeps they are by their voice well
they're always kind of shitting on the
girls there's always a tone of like
stupid bitch yeah instead of being like
no no you should be nice to her she's
making sure you have a fucking gig
retard yeah be nice yeah why do you have
to demean them I know you're good enough
they also try out they do like a lot of
dad jokes like boney yeah she will her
husband she's here with her husband you
imagine how many years five years five
years five years listen why are you
asking this your husband watching you
have sex is that common unusual it's the
first time it's ever happened or ever
had oh and uh this is our I feel like it
sounds like Baba Booey oh right a guy I
got picture him this is the
pre-interview should be he's all nervous
and horny and weird time and of course
it's my first time that my husband
observe what went observe doing what you
doing um what you doing what you doing
yeah gross I feel that for him is really
exciting yeah for me I feel that is
maybe um testing my own strength
trusting your own strength
what do what can I do did you enjoy it
why you wouldn't can I say what I like
about you testing the strength of her
asshole asshole yeah yes sorry I didn't
know you guys man I was in said it okay
asshole
yes but um she's really not a ding dong
this chick is smarter right yeah she's
not your average porno girl like look
how thoughtful her answers are well
she's lived a full life to a far right
yeah she's nine inches press that's what
is wrong with you that's not what she
said you don't hear her saying it like
that no no I'm gonna pull that up in a
moment to prove that you're wrong it's
so horrible it's very bright she's
brighter than the asshole interviewing
her
Oh without quiet she could fucking
school a guy yeah yeah absolutely
glad to hear that okay um were you good
at it
um I'm not sure I I think very honest
yeah she's so thoughtful
I think someone other people have to be
the judge of that while I'm doing it I
feel super good
yeah and that's that's what everybody's
kept on asking me how are you doing I
always an answer come up they're down
here yet
well Kim there's a sure way to know if
you're doing it right
Oh God at the end of your scene with a
guy did he come in yeah
yes you did it congratulations you
succeeded
okay gang Wow okay so usually like to
kind of like live at the end each come I
fixed your dumb now
we can tell the guys that you're how old
um 61 few more days from now okay she is
69 to to money 761 you look spectacular
um to attack you love have you always
been drawn nice to poor asshole looks
nice selfish way to Ronnie why the
monster what happened you could tell he
has tenth degree dad mouth you can in
your the sourness in his yeah I agree
got a real rocking body you made him
come real hard yeah
first of all like making a guy come is
that big of a deal yeah teddy home at
the end of it I just do feel that I
always be as such and yeah um so now to
prove I don't like her even more now
she's the best a wonderful lady Kimmy
Kimmy whoops and I was truly amazed this
is the this isn't there it's really
really comfortable with a lot of
hello out that a lot of artifacts oh
okay
I feel really really comfortable on
being outside and especially with the to
a special and women to gentleman really
treat me very special oh she thinks
that's long ultimate goal is to really
um get them to be really really hot man
view that me come on have a lot to offer
you do girl you do
alright look at her positive self-esteem
this girl's like the Aristotle of porno
some reasonable video though I used to
feel like like I'm talking to my friends
aunt you know and you're like it's not
that I feel like oh you're not
attractive it's just that she just feels
you know maternal yeah she is she's old
burns my right grandma like right here
if you go like okay that's a little bit
cheeky you go oh this is a nice lady you
know I'll call with it
and I feel really satisfied with my
whole body being caressed do you like we
were you were be um kissed and save
beautiful words I don't think they did
all that to her I don't think they're
touch yeah and I feel very very excited
if we could just it's really unexpected
we can't show it on YouTube but I feel
like happy if we could splice in the
actual scene really aroused it's not
it's not that what she's describing
because at all the physical end of it I
feel that there will really be cock nine
and a half inches and plus and plus
Laura's I have never expect expect to
have such a um
beautiful experience she said plus you
know experience I was so hot for them
especially on the scene that they put
their hard cock into my asshole it's so
amazing this is like specially gold just
on some where they put their hard cock
into my asshole
she she's pleading yeah oh yeah it's
she's so into it yeah
this lady is just us she's amazing plus
she said right there the physical end of
it for us we'll really be copied good
nine and a half inches and class prize
no she doesn't say puss I have to say
Express I prize maybe you need to get
these switched out begun here in Pross
you're so mean
it's a nine she's so earnest that's what
it is it's earnest its I've never seen a
pornstar be earnest well let's see how
sweet the scene say
they're not gentlemen and they're not
being night and I'll be next I hate when
they finger it's so aggressively like
that no one no one's one whoops okay
when this is just off her she was
screaming oh man